thanks christos
uh so we've known a long time
in economics and game theory that uh
equilibria things like nash equilibria
but not necessarily optimal tons of
famous examples
prisoners dilemma tragedy of the commons
this morning christos mentioned braces
paradox
uh but something that wasn't obvious at
all until the past 15
years or so was that there's actually
lots of applications lots of classes of
games
that we're really interested in where
you can prove that equilibria while not
fully optimal are approximately optimal
provably okay they're provably near
optimal
so these are so called price of anarchy
bounds
and a number of researchers many in this
room have given a lot of
different such bounds in different
applications over the past 15 years a
lot of greatest hits
uh something really cool has happened
over the past five to seven years though
and what used to be sort of a motley
collection of bounds for different
application domains
has really coalesced into i think a very
cohesive and general theory and so now
as an analyst if you're tasked with
proving uh guarantees for equilibria and
some games that you care about
there's now a quite powerful toolbox
which isolates exactly what are the
details about your application you have
to understand
and then once you understand those
details there are these powerful
theorems that allow you to immediately
extend that
to a very really very strong general
bounds so the subject of these two talks
are going to be
this toolbox which again i think you
know it's powerful but it's also very
user friendly so i hope
uh this sort of empowers you to use
these for for more theorems of your own
so just to make this a little more
concrete let me open with a
representative
result okay and it's okay if you don't
remember what all of the words mean on
this slide i'll fill in all the details
as we go this is
to give you a sense of where we're going
to be going where things are leading
and this is a guarantee which
simultaneously i think is extremely
strong
but secondly in these two talks i'll
give you all of the tools necessary to
prove this theorem and of course many
others so what's this result what's this
price of energy bound so it's about
if you're selling multiple items that
are not identical items okay so you have
to sell a bunch of things
to various bidders and so how are you
gonna do this well if you if you
actually really had to solve this
problem like if tomorrow you literally
had to sell a bunch of things
uh you might start simple right you
might see if you get away with the
simplest imaginable case where you say
look
we've got a lot of good single item
auction formats second price first price
auctions
if we have m items why don't we just run
m single item auctions in parallel
okay or put all of the goods up on ebay
if you like okay
so how well would this work would this
work well would this not work well
so this theorem identifies conditions
under which this extremely simple format
actually gets welfare surprisingly close
to the maximum possible okay
surprisingly close here means
63 percent here equilibrium means bayes
nash equilibria
if i say bayes nash equilibria you
should say what's the prior distribution
actually doesn't matter what the prior
distribution is as long as the
valuations are independent
under a substitute's condition so this
is in the spirit of what professor era
was telling about this morning
so for this theorem we assume that
valuations are submodular meaning that a
bidder
values other items less the marginal
value for items are less as it gets more
items okay so sort of diminishing
returns
so in a substitutes type situation this
very simple auction format is
provably closed for every prior product
distribution for every bayes nash
equilibrium with respect to that
distribution
almost as good as the maximum welfare
and i want you to appreciate this
statement on at least
three different levels okay so first of
all i just think
the question is is really nice and it's
something you actually might really want
to know the answer to right so maybe you
know like
the situation i already gave you're a
seller you have a bunch of items and
you're like well
do i have to come up with some custom
mechanism from scratch to solve this
problem or can i just you know really
just rely on something simple like put
everything on ebay
so this theorem gives you guidance about
when it's okay you need a custom
solution when you don't
or think about someone tasked with
designing a commentary auction you know
for selling spectrum licenses or what
have you
again you want to know you know can we
just pretend like it's the early 90s and
just run a separate simultaneous just
run simultaneous ascending options one
per item
or do we need to incorporate some kind
of more complicated package bidding
where people where bidders can uh submit
a bid on a subset of goods not just
individual goods
again this theorem you can interpret is
trying to help give guidance about it by
saying
in a substitutes type situation separate
single item auctions is really not as
bad as you would expect adding
complexity the auction format can only
gain
a relatively small amount the second
sense in which i want you to appreciate
this theorem is this number okay this 63
percent
all right so you know without context
it's not totally clear whether
you should regard this as a high or a
low number but at least for people who
are used to proving approximation
there's something interesting about this
bound which is even if you thought about
the seemingly much simpler
situation where there's no players
there's no private valuations
okay i just want you to come up with an
algorithm computationally efficient
algorithm
which computes an allocation which is
close to the maximum possible welfare
okay so just approximate the maximum
welfare with an efficient algorithm
the state of the art for that problem is
essentially 63
and it's not easy to design algorithms
which meet the 63
guarantee so despite the fact that on
the design side one has done almost
nothing
one nevertheless can prove that the
equilibria are achieving performance
comparable
to state-of-the-art efficient algorithms
so 63 for
approximating this optimization problem
is pretty impressive
the third sense in which i want you to
appreciate this is just like forget
about it being true
okay so it's impressive this is true but
third that we can actually prove it
okay so why should you be impressed well
this is a statement about every single
bayes national equilibrium
for every single common prior okay
we have no idea what bayes nash
equilibrium look like
in these games no clue in fact if there
was one item
and there were two bidders and the
bidders have different valuation
distributions
even then we don't really understand
what the base nash equilibrium look like
even in a single item first price
auction so we surely don't know much
about what bay's national equipment look
like
at this level generality
characterization would be hopeless
nonetheless we can still prove these
worst case bounds about all equilibria
and again in these talks i'll give you
all of the tools needed to prove results
of this form
all right so we're gonna do the first
two parts today and i'm gonna open with
some work
which now is fairly old it's over five
years old but even if you've seen this
before i think it's important to go
through it because this is going to be
an important analogy to have in your
mind
when we pass to the more complicated
parts in parts two and three
so even though most of these lectures
are going to be about auctions which are
most naturally modeled as incomplete
information games
i want to spend the first part about
full information games i'll also remind
you what the price of anarchy is
introduce you to smooth games in the
paradigm of extension theorems
okay so to jog your memory about the
price of anarchy again this is always
already mentioned this morning by
christos
let me just return to a old setting near
and dear to my heart which is routing
games
it's the same topology christos had all
the numbers are different
so the price of energy what is it it's
really just uh an approximation
guarantee for equilibrium so you compare
two things you have a game you have an
objective function
and you will say well you know how
what's the objective function of an
equilibrium
and then what's the best imaginable
objective function if i hypothetically
had full control
over the system so it's a comparison
between two objects
so in this game there's only one
equilibrium it's easy to see okay both
players have dominant strategies oh i
should tell you what the payoffs are
so there's two there's two players each
has three strategies the the three pass
from s to t
the edge labels what that means is that
means the cost incurred by a player as a
function of the number of players
x using the edge okay x is going to be
one or two because there's only two
players
so this is never worse than four so this
beats five
the five x is always better than twelve
so the dominant strategy is for a player
to take the zigzag path
so the unique equilibrium has both
players on the zigzag path each of them
incurs a cost of
14 for a joint cost of 28. the
assumption is that this is what we'd
ideally like to minimize
so the second question is could we do
better if we had full control over the
system
and we could if we split the players on
different paths
then they'd stop interfering with each
other yeah the green player would still
have 14 but at least the red player
would have dropped to 10.
so the joint cost is 24. okay so the
ratio between these two quantities
and this by definition is the price of
anarchy is 7 over 6
28 over 24. so in some sense selfish
behavior is costing us you know 16
in terms of the average delay of players
in this particular example
as you know there can be many equilibria
and there's various ways you can handle
that but
what i'm going to focus on in these
lectures is the traditional worst case
guarantee where if you have many
equilibria you want a bound that applies
to every single one
this absolves you from worrying about
what equilibrium might be reached by the
players
okay so that's the definition of the
price of anarchy
now i'm sure i mean a number of people
in this
room have proven these bounds before but
for the benefit of those of you who
haven't
let's just pause and say you know if i
gave it to you as a homework assignment
you know prove the best upper bound you
can on the price of anarchy and routing
networks like this
how you know what would that proof look
like how would you go about it
and the good news is uh that you can
really mostly just follow your nose
and then when the occasion calls for it
do a little algebra okay so let me show
you what i mean by that
so let me do some notation okay so this
is really for
any game with a finite number of players
each of them has a
later of a utility function for now it's
a cost function so this is a strategy
profile like a traffic pattern and a
network this is the cost that player
incurs in this particular strategy
profile
and again the assumption is we want to
minimize the joint cost
so we're supposed to prove a bound on
the price of anarchy so fundamentally
we need to relate the cost the objective
function value
of an optimal solution s star versus a
arbitrary nash equilibrium s okay so
pick your favorite arbitrary nash
equilibrium
we start with the equilibrium cost
really what we want is a chain of
inequalities only getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
terminating in the cost of s star times
some constant
okay that's what a proof like this is
going to look like equilibrium cost of
some constant factor times the optimal
cost
so we start with the equilibrium cost
which by definition is the joint cost
and now you know certainly one main
thing we have going for us
is our assumption that s is a nash
equilibrium okay so if s was some
arbitrarily crazy outcome we wouldn't be
able to prove anything but it's a nash
equilibrium so we should use that
hypothesis
and so how should we do that well we
could say well what does it mean to be a
nash equilibrium
it means if any player did anything
different it would only get worse
okay so if we hypothetically think of
player i switching to some other
strategy we're going to get a inequality
the right direction okay the
corresponding
term will only go up holding other
player strategies fixed
so hypothetical deviations gives us
upper bounds on individual player costs
that's good
we want upper bounds so that leaves the
question
okay so what hypothetical deviation
should we use
this is sort of a sort of degree of
freedom for us as an analyst
you know here there's only two things on
the board this equilibrium is the
optimal solution
so as what i'll call a baseline strategy
we can think about well what if player i
switched to what we wish it was doing
it's strategy s star i and the optimal
solution
okay so the ith term here is the outcome
in which
i has unilaterally switched to its
strategy in the optimal solution
okay it was a nash equilibrium so that i
term only goes up
we can do this for all n of the players
all n of the terms only go up
okay so i would sometimes refer to this
s star as baseline strategies
okay it's really saying you know if a
player you know switch to one of these
baseline strategies because we're at an
equilibrium we could only go up
so this is what i meant by following our
nose
now without saying anything about the
game it's not clear how we'd make any
progress okay but let's say now actually
there's a class of games we care about
routing games with linear cost functions
right we know it can be as bad as 7
6 can it be higher if so
how much higher could it be so what
might the rest of the proof look like
okay so we're stuck right here so the
thing to realize so just at a very meta
level
this is some number that we don't care
about at all per se
this is some weird entangled version of
these two outcomes s
star for a price of energy bound the
only two quantities we care about
are the equilibrium cost and the optimal
cost so in some sense
the rest of the proof implicitly or
explicitly what it's going to be doing
is establishing a relationship an upper
bound
on this entangled quantity in terms of
the two quantities we care about
the equilibrium and optimal costs so
that's going to look something like this
this is what the rest of the proof is
going to look like you could imagine
right so here's where we stopped last
time this is what we don't care about
these are the two quantities we care
about you could imagine more complicated
functions of those two costs but we'll
be
able to get a get away with linear
combinations okay
so we're going to think about the rest
of the proof looking like upper bounding
this entangled term
by a linear combination with
coefficients lambda and mu
of the optimal and equilibrium costs
so lambda and u here are parameters mu
as we'll see should be less than one
lambda we're hoping is a small constant
okay five thirds and one thirds would be
good parameters to keep in mind if you
like so suppose we could prove this
okay and who knows if we can and for
what got parameter values but suppose we
could prove this
then we'd be done okay
we take the last slide so using the nash
equilibrium hypothesis the equilibrium
cost is upper bounded by this entangled
term
by assumption by star this is upper
bounded by a linear combination of the
optimal and equilibrium costs
since mu is less than one we can
subtract from both sides divide through
by one minus mu
and we conclude that indeed the cost of
this arbitrary equilibrium s
is no more than lambda over one minus mu
times the optimal cost okay since the
equilibrium was arbitrary this is the
same as a price of energy bound
of lambda over one minus mu okay the
smaller the lambda the smaller the mu
the better this bound the closer this
bound is to one okay
so all i've done now is i've reduced
what these bounds might look like
to proving a statement like this for the
best constants lambda and u that you can
and that's where you have to do a little
algebra and that algebra is going to
depend on the details of your game
and so many people have done these
computations for different games there's
a very rich theory now
let me just continue with the routing
game example and show you sort of a
canonical uh
variant of this and this is not
something i want you to understand in
detail at all this is due to chris
lu and kuzupius and what it proves is
that the
price of anarchy in those routing games
can be two point it can't be any higher
than 2.5 okay and that bound is tight
it's known to be tight
so let's start at the bottom okay so
ultimately
so oh i meant to write this on the board
this is a good expression to have
available
these are the base lines okay
so this was the kind of kind of
inequality we wanted okay so i've just
restated that in the bottom
of the slide here here's the entangled
quantity optimal equilibrium costs
lambda i've set to five thirds and mu to
one third because those turn out to be
the optimal parameter values
so how would you prove a statement like
this for routing games with linear cost
functions
well observation one is that you know in
these routing games everything just
adds over the edges okay the objective
function value players costs and so on
so this really reduces to proving the
analogous inequality
on a single edge at once if you can
prove it for every single edge
then you have it for the full-blown
traffic patterns
even on an edge now you can use the
assumption that the cost function's f
fine
and you can say oh well the worst case
actually is when you just have the
identity function
x and so you just need the analogous
version of this inequality for a single
link
with the identity function that
inequality looks like this
okay so it's a relationship between a
product of a pair of integers and those
integers
squared and now you do some algebra you
figure out what the best choice of
lambda mu
is and you discover after a little bit
of elbow grease it's five thirds and one
third
remember that the bound that you get is
lambda over one minus mu
so with lambda five thirds and mu one
third this was going to be 2.5 as
promised
okay so the upshot being again we did
some just follow your nose stuff which
would work for any game whatsoever
and then we did a bunch of algebra
specific to routing games which gave us
the magic number
of 2.5 now i want you to notice
something
again the point is not to go through
this in detail
but even from the high level description
i gave you
there should be an important property
which is evident which is
in all of this algebra never did we use
the fact
that this was an equilibrium s
so if you remember in our motivating
statement we wanted to take an arbitrary
equilibrium s
say it was close to an optimal solution
s star so we're only worrying about the
case where s was in equilibrium
in this sub piece for this lemma we did
a bunch of algebra just using additivity
of the congestion games using the
fineness of the cost functions
and then some kind of relationship
between pairs of integers
none of this has anything to do with sbn
equilibrium this inequality actually is
proven
by the exact same algebra no matter what
the outcome
s is okay any traffic pattern in one of
these networks doesn't matter if it's an
equilibrium or not
it also doesn't matter if it's an
optimal solution or not but that's
that's not relevant
okay so the algebra at least in this
particular case of routing games
is uh you know it does it does prove the
inequality that we wanted but an even
stronger form
than what was required okay so we're
going to give this stronger form a name
we're going to say a game is lambda mu
smooth with respect to particular
baselines as
star if the same inequality we had holds
but not just for one equilibrium s but
for every single outcome
s okay and again the algebra on the last
slide
proves exactly this property with lambda
five thirds and mu one third
for routing games with affine cost
functions okay
so game is land and you smooth with
respect to baseline's s star and just
think of star as the optimal solution
if you can disentangle s from s star
charging against a suitable linear
combination of the individual costs
no matter what s is because you choose s
star first
this should be true simultaneously for
every s
that's what it means for a game to be
smooth okay
so if the game is landing use smooth
then certainly the price of anarchy is
the most land over 1 minus mu this is an
even stronger condition
than what we needed before before we
only needed star to hold for equilibria
s
smoothness is a definition
simultaneously for all outcomes
including
non-equilibrium outcomes okay
so what right definitions are really
cheap
right anyone can get up on a board and
write down any definition they want
what makes the definition interesting
two things examples
implications all right i've given you
one example
affine routing i find routing games
which are smooth with nice parameters
there are many many many others dozens
of others there's now so many
it's actually futile to try to list all
the smoothness arguments on a single
slot and i'm not going to do it okay so
there's dozens and dozens
of examples of interesting games which
meet this condition with
small values of the parameters so those
are the examples what about the
implications why should you
care if a game satisfies this condition
i mean it gives you a bound on the price
of energy of nash equilibria but we
didn't need the stronger condition for
that
right so what use is having a stronger
condition
so to answer that question let me
mention sort of a different research
agenda that this dovetails with
which there was a lot of nice work on
about 10 years ago
and so a number of people observed a
potential conceptual issue with price of
energy bounds
right so what does the price of energy
bound mean it means if a game is at an
equilibrium
then the outcome of the game is close to
optimal
that's what it means and why are we not
satisfied with this kind of statement
well we're a little concerned about the
strength of the hypothesis
if the game is at an equilibrium then
blah blah blah blah
why might a game not be at an
equilibrium well
it depends on what kind of equilibrium
we're talking about but pure equilibria
which is actually what i was talking
about so far they don't even exist
in lots of games as you know they do
always exist in those routing games but
in general they don't always exist
so then you're not talking about
anything that's an equilibrium that
doesn't exist
makes nash equilibria so they exist in
in finite games
but they are hard to compute in various
senses okay ppid complete
even for two player by matrix games even
harder once you have more players
okay so the concern is that you know
the in the games we're looking at the
equilibria are good but the players will
be playing out of equilibrium
and therefore the performance of the
system or the performance in the game
will not be near optimal
okay that was sort of on a lot of
people's minds mid last decade
and there is a long stream of work
approaching this from many different
directions
okay i'm only going to focus on one of
the directions in terms of no regret
sequences
but there's lots of nice work in terms
of best response sequences and other
things as well
okay so for today the story is going to
be the following
all right so we're concerned that
players fail to play nash equilibrium
and our price of energy bounds don't
apply
well if players aren't playing nash
equilibria then what are they playing
okay we'd like to weaken the assumption
to make it behaviorally more plausible
now we need some kind of behavioral
assumption right
i mean if you have a routing game and
some player just plays on some link that
has cost a billion
you're not going to prove anything
interesting right so you need some
control over what players are doing
now this is a problem it's this idea of
what other equilibrium concepts this is
a problem where there's a rich
literature
whose shoulders we can stand on okay so
in particular uh there's a lot of work
in both game theory and computer science
stating you know roughly that it's
actually not
that hard for players to learn to play
more permissive equilibrium concepts
like correlated equilibria
or coarse correlated equilibria okay so
for the people with a more
kind of computer science background this
corresponds to algorithms that minimize
internal regret
this corresponds to algorithms that
minimize external regret like say
multiplicative weights
okay but the takeaway from this slide is
that while nash equilibria appear to be
difficult to compute even by centralized
algorithms
there's lightweight learning algorithms
for players such that
the empirical distribution of their
joint plate converges to these bigger
equilibrium sets correlated equilibrium
of course correlated equilibria
okay so i will so i'm not going to
define i will define no regret sequences
in a couple slides otherwise i'm not
going to define these formally
but i'm satisfied if you are just aware
of the following picture
okay which is in any game you can look
at a hierarchy of equilibria okay where
you make
weaker and weaker behavioral assumptions
and therefore more and more things get
deemed in equilibrium
okay and therefore it's more plausible
that play is somewhere in that set
so the smallest set is just the pure
nash equilibria okay so
everybody puts a deterministic strategy
no one can do better these need not
exist so that's a problem
mix and dash equilibria those are only
more general they exist but they can be
hard to compute
even already once you get the correlated
equilibria what's cool is these are
computationally tractable okay you can
write them down as a linear program
or as i mentioned there's learning
algorithms where the empirical
distribution of joint plate converges
and then course quality equilibria
corresponding to no regret sequences
this is even bigger so this in some
sense even easier to compute even easier
to learn
so and so in other words when you if you
prove price of anarchy bounds about
these outer two sets
we sort of dodge the intractability
critique okay these are outcomes where
if we can prove a bound for every single
outcome in these big sets
all of a sudden it starts looking quite
meaningful okay for example it implies
that
if players are using certain learning
algorithms then the price of anarchy
guarantee holds
all right the problem of course
price of anarchy it's a worst case
measure it's governed by the worst of
all of your equilibria
so the more things are equilibria the
worse your price of energy
okay can only increase with the size of
the equilibrium set
okay so it's going to only get bigger as
you go up this venn diagram
so therefore the coolest thing that
could be true right what you're really
hoping for
is that actually the price of energy all
the way out here is exactly the same as
it is down
here okay it's not going to be any
better if it's different it's only worse
so you're hoping that the price of
energy for the biggest set is the same
as for the smallest set
now that's not going to be true in
general okay but it's going to be
true under conditions which are met in
many cases the other thing
it's not going to be true sort of on a
game by game basis but when you're
talking about the worst case price of
anarchy over classes of games which is
what we often
do in computer science then all of a
sudden you start
being having this coolest possible
result but the price of energy is
exactly the same
for the most permissive set as for the
most stringent set
but the realized in different games
the worst cases no so the way it tends
to work i don't have a general theorem
about this but for all the cases i've
thought through carefully
there's a single worst case game which
is bad for all of the equilibrium
concepts simultaneously
basically because they wind up just
being you know sort of
uh the worst equilibrium is a pure
equilibrium and therefore it's all of
the other
three as well so what more happens is if
you do have these games where the best
pure equilibrium is better than the
best sorry the worst uh pure nash is
better than the worst mixed nast which
is better than the worst correlated etc
but you know those are games where the
pure equilibrium are somehow much better
than the worst case bound for pure
equilibria okay
so for a specific game like if i just
gave you one network these 10 nodes
these 17 edges
you really would get numbers like you
know 1.1 1.4 or 1.8 2.2
in general but when i think about you
know what's the worst case price of
energy bound for every routing game with
outline cost functions
all of these are going to be 2.5
okay so let me prove to you the
following results so this is the
connection right so i told you about the
smoothness condition and i didn't tell
you why you should care why is it
interesting if the game satisfies the
smoothness condition
i just said you know this is satisfied
by many existing price of anarchy proofs
so here's the reason why you should care
so if you have a game which is lambda mu
smooth
then not only is the price of anarchy of
pure equilibria at most lambda over one
minus mu but actually
every no regret sequence which i'll
define for you in the next slide but
it's really a sort of much wider set of
stuff than nash equilibria
also obeys exactly the same
approximation guarantee okay so remember
lambda over 1 minus mu
this is what we were proving before for
pure equilibria this theorem is
basically saying
whether we knew it or not we were
proving exactly the same approximation
guarantee for the
baddest of those four equilibrium sets
okay
so this is the this is kind of the first
meta theorem
which says base well i'll see more about
that later let me actually do the do the
proof and then talk more about
interpretations
all right so what is a no regret
sequence okay
so we fix the games like a fixed network
and we think about the game being played
over and over again on t consecutive
days okay so like
rush hour traffic on a bunch of mornings
in a row
so it's no regret if the following is
true
every player i okay so every player is
adaptively perhaps trying to pick
a good strategy on each day you know
like a different road to work every day
it had some average cost okay over the t
days
and so the no regret says well in
hindsight after seeing the cost
after seeing what other players did
every single day
you're allowed to best respond okay with
a single action playing every single day
okay so in other words suppose you gave
a player of an option of going back in
time
and instead of doing what it actually
did instead picking its favorite action
q-i and playing q-i day after day after
day
okay so no regret just means that
players were sufficiently smart as they
played this game over time
to do at least as well as the best fixed
strategy
okay the best fixed strategy
so as i mentioned on a couple slides ago
there's some very lightweight learning
algorithms that give you this guarantee
multiplicative weights is one you hear
about a lot these days there is a regret
term which goes to zero as t
goes to infinity i'm just going to
ignore this this is this sort of
harmlessly gets carried through the
analysis on the next slide
okay and then one special case of a
neurograd sequence is you just pick your
favorite nash equilibrium
and you play that again and again and
again and again and again that's a no
red sequence but the whole point of this
is
no red sequences can get much much
weirder than just a pure nash
equilibrium over and over again
okay so it's really only an equilibrium
condition on average over time
in no way can we conclude that any of
these out outcomes are equilibria in any
sense
okay so
this is a theorem or once you have the
definitions the proof just writes itself
now you really just follow your nose and
you don't even ever have to do any
algebra
okay so we have a smooth game randomly
smooth game we have a no regret sequence
s1 through st
let's prove a bound of lambda over one
minus mu so let me just multiply through
by capital t just to save notation
so we're summing over the days we just
look at the total the joint cost on day
t
which we expand over the players just
like we did at the beginning of the talk
now this is actually the step which
seems like trouble compared to our
national equilibrium analysis
at the beginning because what was the
next step we did when we were following
our nose last time
we said oh well s is in equilibrium so
if it switches to s star i that gives us
an upper bound on the individual player
cost which is good
but you know a given s sub t remember
this is not an equilibrium
we do not know that these things are
equilibria we only have a time average
equilibrium condition over the whole
sequence
so if i walk up to player i
at day t and i forced it to switch to
this s
star strategy its cost might well go
down
because it might be better off because
again there's no assumption that st is
in equilibrium
so let's defer the issue with some
notation so just define delta
i t as the amount that player i gets
better
if on day t i force it to switch to s
star i
okay so in a nash equilibrium this would
be non-positive
here it could be positive okay so it's
how much better it got by switching on
day i
on day t to star i and now hopefully you
can see where this is going we're going
to use the smoothness condition
to disentangle all these entangled terms
we're going to use the no regret
condition
to control all of the deltas okay
so the smoothness condition that's this
over here
except remember smoothness by definition
requires disentangling no matter what
the outcome
s is whether or not it's an equilibrium
and that's exactly what we need here
because we have no idea what this what
the strategy what this strategy profile
st
is could be anything our only control is
again time averaged over the sequence
so it's really good that our assumption
allows us to disentangle in particular
this entangled term
okay so that gives us lambda times the
optimal cost plus mu times day t's cost
let's look at these regret terms so the
way i want you to think about this
is first fix a player i and then think
about summing over t
what was delta i t delta that's how much
better i gets
if i force it to switch to s star i on
day t
so what's the sum over t of delta i t
that's how much player i gets better
overall
if every single day i force it to switch
to the time and variant strategy s star
i
okay so the no regret condition exactly
says that for every player i
that inner sum is non-positive
individual terms could be positive
but the sum over all the days is
non-positive okay so i can just drop
that without harm
right and then dividing through and
rearranging gives us the desired lambda
over one minus mu bound
okay so here's a cartoon which is how i
kind of like thinking about this and how
i want you to think about things later
in the talk as well
i think this is an extension theorem in
the following sense so this is a tool
for the lazy analyst
present company definitely not excluded
um so you know we want to prove a
theorem
and in the conclusion of our theorem we
want to have the most meaningful
guarantee possible
right which means we really want to sort
of be able to say that every equilibrium
from the biggest set possible is near
optimal like course quality equilibrium
no regret
course available and so on so boy would
it be simpler if we could just think
about pure nash equilibria and indeed
this is actually
this analysis is the fun part this is
where you learn what's special about
your game when you just think about pure
nash equilibria
and so the goal of an extension theorem
is to just take a bound
it's meant to be a black box translation
that takes as input
a price of anarchy bound on pure nash
equilibria and spits out as output
the exact same price of energy bound no
degradation for this more permissive
equilibrium set
okay that's what it does now again you
can't have this totally generally
because there are games where
some equilibria are better than others
but what we learned we've learned that
if you prove a guarantee
on pure nash equilibria using a
smoothness proof
okay by establishing the stronger lambda
new smoothness condition
then that type of price of anarchy proof
for pure equilibria
does extend losslessly out to no regret
sequences
okay so it's a special type of bound on
pure nash equilibria
can be extended by the argument on the
last slide to extend automatically to no
regret sequences
yes automatically by that
you gave me hope yes exactly so
basically
i mean in some ways think of it this way
so the hypothesis here is land immune
smoothness
the way i think of that is you proved
the price of energy bound on pure
equilibria
following a certain template is that the
way you'd actually get the most
efficient way to prove it i mean
i'm trying to think about this in your
paper it's not
the game is really well chosen it's not
obvious to me what the lambda mu
smoothness is so it's not
clear if i was starting to novo to get a
price of energy bound looking at pure
ash
but i'm not is is this establishing the
stronger sweetness condition
typically as easy as proving the more
restrictive results i mean
good question so the question is
basically
right so you know if you just wanted to
prove a price of energy bound
you could do it you could put whatever
you want right and now i'm tying your
hands i'm making you do it a certain way
i have a reason for it it's because i
want these these sort of more general
statements
but you know how much are you losing so
um with so that something very strong
can be stated for routing games
and a couple other games which is that
actually you can prove
that you lose nothing from smoothness so
in other words if you take the minimum
provable bound
by any smoothness argument you always
get
exactly the right answer okay so you can
prove that totally generically for
congestion games
that is not true for every single class
of games one might care about
and it's an open question to understand
better which games have i call this
tightness which games have this
tightness property which classes games
do not
but um
yeah so if you look at routing games on
parallel links
those are not you cannot prove the tight
bound to four thirds using a smoothness
argument
but what do you say probably i thought
you said that
in games with arbitrary network
topologies right so whenever i talk
about routing games with cost functions
yes so right so so so when you talk
about routing games i guess there's two
parents well there's a few parameters
but i usually focus on the cost
functions
but you can also say what are the
networks i'm allowed to use
and so the tightness happens when you're
allowed to use any network you want
okay but if i say oh no you're only
allowed to use parallel networks as many
links as you want
but you have another theorem that says
that parallel links tell you everything
about
so that's what a non-atomic model yeah
so for the non-atomic model actually
parallel links capture the full
complexity but with atomic games you get
these separations depending on the
topological complexity
so
so there is some understanding of how
much you lose with moon i would say
empirically you know if you just look at
the literature
pretty much so there are some games so
so to give you a non example so there
are some games where basically
you pure equilibrium are good and
smoothness won't let you prove it at all
and the biggest disad like a good
example of a total disaster would be
like a network formation game
where you know people form links
unilateral bilateral i don't care
and often in these models if it's
disconnected people have like minus
infinity payoffs or really bad payoffs
and if you try to check these smoothness
conditions they're just totally a
disaster but pure equilibrium are often
very good in many of these network
models
on the other hand right so even mixed
nash equilibria
are total disasters when you have those
that kind of pay off setup
and so the statement i would say
empirically looking at the literature
is like pretty much for all the games
you know i'm sure there's some
exceptions somewhere but i can't think
of one outside my head
like whenever you can actually prove
good mixed nash equilibrium bounds
it seems to be a smoothness proof behind
it that's not a formal statement routing
games it's a formal statement that's
just an empirical statement
as far as you know if you so as far as
like how do you come up with these
yourself
uh i mean i guess again sort of
empirically
how do you normally you start trying to
know like what's the guess going to be
so you try some small games you can come
up with some bad examples
then you start sort of trying to prove
some upper bounds maybe for special
cases
and it just seems like you know you know
like a black you know like kind of some
gravitational force you just get pulled
into these smoothness arguments
just so sort of how it seems to work
okay so are you going to interpret the
smoothness condition at all
i'm not going to interpret the smoothest
condition at all i mean i can only give
you a very vague
motivating the word smoothness while
you're at it sure
so
i mean i think so it's a little i mean
so a valid complaint would be
you know i'm just looking i'm thinking
about you know games are basically
arbitrary
finite strategy spaces so there's really
like no non-trivial topology so like
what could i mean by smooth and this
kind of thing right
but you know still you know when i look
at this
it's sort of playing the role of kind of
a lipschitz like condition
in my opinion so basically you have some
starting point some starting strategy
profile s
and then you think about doing sort of a
one-dimensional deviation and then you
have a collection of these
one-dimensional deviations it's almost
like
you know you're in a cube and you take
kind of like you know a star
of deviations and you're basically
saying you know you can control
how much the joint cost varies
as you look over all of these deviations
and somehow you know what does it mean
to control it
the thing which is so this is somehow
like you know
proportional to you know so this is like
your starting point and this is kind of
how far you went
and this is parameterized by the
directions that you're going in
partial derivatives or something i mean
i don't i don't i don't know of any
extremely crisp characterization of of
it and i'm not convinced that there is
one
frankly um i'm sorry
i'm not convinced that there's any crisp
reinterpretation of
this exact smoothness condition so
the one thing the one thing one thing
which is interesting which is going on
is there's some new work using fresh
duality uh to ban the price of anarchy
so i think
i think nikhil debener's maybe doing
part of this
um who's here and that
you know at least there's sort of you
get sort of duality type interpretations
um and but it's sort of an open question
it seems sort of related to the
smoothness stuff but it's an open
question to actually connect them
so so it's not clear to me that one
would ever come up with this concept
unless you were focused on proving price
of energy balance but if you believe
that we care about this then i think you
should care about the definition
following up on drew's point i i look at
that condition and i want to interpret
it as saying
my actions do not have a big effect on
your
costs yeah not player by player
but in some player average sense yeah so
if i interpret it that way then it seems
like the theorem says
if i'm in a game where my actions do not
have a big effect in the aggregate
on other people's costs then is it so
surprising that
under the most permissive solution
concept i have the same bound as i do
under the more restrictive solutions you
know i think the fact that there's
positive correlation
between you know what you said uh and
price of energy bounds is maybe not that
surprising the fact that you'd have such
tight numerical exactness coming out of
this i
don't see any way to you know see why
that would be operatory obvious
so you know i agree like if the right
answer is 2.5 and this gave you like a
10. you're like oh we're ballpark and
then we kind of like well maybe that's
trivial but
to actually nail it and then nail it in
a way you can even prove that it nails
it in very generic senses
i i think there's something reasonably
fundamental about it
you don't you don't need an again to
face most with direct respect to
every strategy profile you only need a
gun to piece most
with respect to a
strategy profile right excellent point
so the way i've stated this is i said
you should be
so remember with respect to something
that's referring to the s star
so this is stated where s star is an
optimal solution if there's many you can
pick whichever one you want
the same proof says oh if you want to
pick s star to be a two approximation
then you're just going to lose that 2 in
this bound to get a 2 lambda over 1
minus mu
and conceivably that flexibility could
be useful to choose
use sub-optimal outcomes is there
something without
this smooth property but still has a
good
idea and okay advice privacy or total
energy
i'm sorry is this a necessary condition
i mean
is there some example sometimes
sometimes without
this property but still has a good
privacy i know
yes there is so in many cases
they go together but these network
formation games
are an example where this doesn't work
at all but it still has a good price of
energy for pure equilibria
but if you look in the literature i
would say 70
or so this gives you exactly what you
want so it's by no means everything
okay but it's really a quite wide swath
okay so let me uh in my remaining times
say a little
segue a bit into games of incomplete
information so this is all games of full
information
so a lot of these talks are going to be
about auctions auctions we think about
incomplete information and again
so this will be a little quick if you've
never seen games of incomplete
information before but i think it'll
still give you the gist
but first of all like what's the
difference right so well you know like
imagine
ava and i are playing rock paper
scissors right this game of full
information
why if she plays rock and i play
scissors
she knows my payoff my payoff's minus
one because her rock
breaks my scissors right doesn't get
complete information she observes the
outcome she knows my payoff
if ava and i are playing in a first
price auction and ava observes me win
at a price of seven dollars she does not
know my payoff
okay because my payoff depends not only
on the fact that i won this auction and
paid seven dollars
it depends on my valuation what i would
have been willing to pay
okay if my valuation was 10 my utility
would be three if my valuation was four
my utility would be minus three
okay so auctions right you don't
generally know exactly what other people
are willing to pay
so it's a game of incomplete information
so how does this change okay so let me
just describe it in terms of the deltas
of what we've seen
so there's still players there's still
actions and so by the way now
now think about auctions from now on
okay until further notice
so you can do all this stuff generally
for games general games inventory
information but let's just think about
auctions
so actions here will be bids types think
of these as just valuations
okay so a type is known only to player i
right
like evaluation for a good so
now the assumption when we do so-called
bayes nash equilibrium analysis
as a player you don't actually know the
other player's action i don't know how
say in a first-place auction the other
player is going to bid because they
don't know its valuation
now a strategy is a mapping from values
to bids okay so as a player i might use
the strategy
you know if my value is 10 then i will
bid seven if my value is 12
then i will bid nine okay so strategies
or functions from the private types
to actions how do players reason about
the other players
well again we want to have player i not
know
what others valuations are but we'll
make the common prior assumption
so all valuations are drawn from some
commonly known distribution
okay so everybody knows the distribution
you only know your own
type realization you do not know the
realization of the other players
okay and then what does it mean to do a
best response it just means you do the
best thing for yourself
given what you know what do you know at
the time that you take an action
you know your own valuation so again
think like bidding in a first price
auction
you know your own valuation you know the
distribution
from which others valuations were drawn
and you know
their strategies their mappings from
valuations to actions
so by virtue of having a distribution
over over their valuations and knowing
their strategies you have a distribution
over their actions like over their bids
ergo you can best respond you say given
that this is the distribution of bids
what's my expected utility maximizing
bid
for example so these can get tricky so
let me just remind you of a couple
examples
suppose you have a first price auction n
bidders
let's say they're all iid from zero one
okay
so i'll just state it and let you check
it as an exercise that the bayes nash
equilibrium
is forever so it's the first price
auction so you're going to bid less than
your value
and the exact amount that you should be
less than your value is n minus one over
n
so if there's two bidders you should bid
half your value if there's three bidders
you should be two thirds of your value
and so on
so the more competitive the auction the
less you will shade your bid
okay so that's the bayes nash
equilibrium for
and notice this is the form that i said
this is a mapping given the valuation it
tells you what the bit is
okay so this is a nice equilibrium if
you care about price of anarchy bounds
because you'll notice that because this
mapping is the same for every player
the player who bids the highest will
also be the player with the highest
valuation
so the winner of this auction is going
to be the player with the highest
valuation
if you hear about welfare mechanization
that's exactly what you want okay so
this is actually a full welfare based
nash equilibrium okay when bidders are
id from a
uniform distribution this same
conclusion holds much more generally for
iid bidders not just uniform bidders but
as soon as bidders are not identical
keep them independent but not identical
things start getting a little weird
so you have two bitters valuations drawn
uniformly from zero one and zero two
okay then no bayes nash equilibrium has
full welfare
equivalently sometimes the lower value
bidder
will be the sorry the lower value player
will submit the higher bid and win the
item that's what it means to not be full
welfare sometimes the wrong player wins
why does that happen well so morally
what did we learn from this exercise
right from a bitter the more competitive
it is
the higher you should bid okay so if you
have one strong bitter and one weak
bitter
from the strong bidders perspective it's
like they have weak competition
so they're going to shade their bid a
lot from the weak bidder's perspective
it's like they have strong competition
so they're going to shade their bid not
very much
okay so because they have different
shading strategies you get inversions in
the bids and you can have welfare loss
all right so yeah one thing to realize
here is just that you are going to shave
more even in the low territory
yeah i mean relative to what you did
if you were facing a different id bidder
to yourself say
well i say of course yeah i mean in
particular i mean some of this is
trivial like you say right so like
you're never going to bid more than one
for example right but i mean it's more
than that you're really going to just
shave much more aggressively if you're
the strong bitter
yeah but i mean so what i want to point
out to you is that you know this
is actually like a really really
fundamental question here
like just staring us in the face right
so
from price to energy perspective
symmetric first-person auction is not
interesting
i mean for good reason you know for a
nice reason they just work really well
if you believe in equilibrium analysis
non-identical bidders
you do not have full efficiency and
it was as far as i know basically never
studied in economics you know
trying to quantify what kind of
efficiency loss was possible or not
possible
in these kinds of first price auctions
and is right in the wheelhouse of the
price of anarchy questions
okay and in fact it remains an open
question now
exactly what is the price of anarchy in
first price auctions with independent
bidder valuations
there's some nice bounds about it which
i'll talk about but i just want to point
out even just for first price auctions
there's completely novel open questions
you can ask
because of this perspective
okay so notice
right so when we talk about bayes nash
equilibria
we talk about the base nash equilibria
it's with respect to a prior
distribution
okay if you change the prior
distribution it changes players
how they think it changes their
expectations changes their best
responses changes the equilibria
changes the game okay so you cannot
speak about doing basic natural
analysis without saying what the prior
is
so now oh boy okay so how should we set
the prior
right any particular choice of i mean
you know you could have it be uniform
something but kind of any prior would
feel pretty arbitrary
right so if we can get away with it
what we'd really love to do is prove a
price of energy bound about bayes nash
equilibria
that applies no matter what the prior
distribution is
okay for every single prior distribution
we'd like some fixed universal constant
approximation
okay so let's it's not clear if we can
get that or not but let's just think it
through a little bit
so what would it mean to prove a price
of energy on bayes nash equilibria for
all possible prior distributions
well here's one type of prior
distribution a point mass
you deterministically know everybody's
valuations okay
that's a special case so that's the
that's sort of the induced
full information right so this would be
like a first price auction with known
valuations
so if you prove a positive result for
every possible
power distribution you're certainly
proving that positive result is a
special case
for every possible induced full
information game
okay you have no choice that's a special
case of what you're trying to prove
in the contra positive a bottleneck to
any bayes nash equilibrium bound
is negative results for the full
information case
so remember when we had the hierarchy of
equilibria and we passed to the much
more permissive course coil equilibria
we said the coolest thing that could be
true was that it was no worse than pure
equilibria
because it couldn't be better same thing
here what's the coolest statement that
could be true about bayes nash
equilibria with respect to an arbitrary
prior
the best case scenario is that it's no
worse
than the price of energy of nash
equilibria in the induced full
information games
when you fix the full type vector it can
only be worse than that
best case scenario is that it's exactly
the same okay for worst case prior
distribution bounds
now phrase that way it really suggests
this extension theorem paradigm
right which is meant to take bounds from
a special case and lift them losslessly
to the general case
so what would our idealized extension
theorem looked like for bayes nash
equilibria
well here's what we want right so like
we said at least for now let's explore
the idea that we have a bayes nash price
of energy bound for every possible prior
distribution okay that's what we want
so this is going to be the output of the
extension theorem what's the input
well we're going to input like the
weakest possible necessary condition
okay which is the so say we're shooting
for a price of energy of alpha
at the very least the price of energy
better be alpha or better for every
induced full information gain
okay that's a necessary condition for
this conclusion
now again probably we're going to have
some restriction on how that price of
energy bound is proved
so that's why i added here let's suppose
we can use a smoothness type argument
meaning inequalities of this type to
establish
in every induced full information game
that the price of energy of pure
equilibria
is alpha or better okay
so i think this is sort of the the
biggest hope for uh for an extension
theorem
and again as a lazy analyst this is
exactly what you want because this is
stuff we know how to do
and this is the stuff we want to
conclude
all right so here's the cartoon i think
you get the cartoon
all right so we want we want to conclude
things about mixed-based nash
equilibrium incomplete information games
mixing makes proofs harder incomplete
information certainly makes proofs
harder so maybe we can prove it just in
the full information pure nash
equilibrium case
and have an extension theorem to do the
dirty work for us
all right so let me tell you um about
how this is going to work right so this
is going to be a recap of the full
what we did in the full information case
in the first part of the talk
and again i'm just going to describe the
deltas necessary to get this to work in
games of incomplete information and
there's a number of ways to adapt
smoothness to games of incomplete
information
and i'm just going to tell you about one
you know fairly one optimized for the
applications i'm going to focus on in
these talks okay but know that there are
other paradigms as well
so here's what we did in the full
information case so we fixed the game so
back then we were thinking about routing
games
we chose baselines which should be an
optimal outcome and like in a routing
game
there's usually no flexibility here
usually there's just sort of one optimal
you know routing outcome then you prove
that for all
outcomes s you have this smoothness
inequality okay this is the same thing
that's up on the whiteboard
and then we proved an extension theorem
which actually says the lambda over one
minus mu bound
holds for no regret sequences okay so
that's what we did
so what do we need to change for say a
first price auction to really just keep
first price auctions in your mind
let's start with step one so in step one
we
we we wanted to have the optimal
outcomes be fixed
so remember when they're private types
even to know what the optimal outcome is
that's only well defined once you've
fixed people's valuations
right you can't talk about welfare
without knowing what people's valuations
are
so here we're going to fix a setting
like a first price single item auction
and we're going to fix the private
valuations of the bidders
okay so this is like looking at an
induced complete information setup
this now fixes the optimal outcomes okay
for a single item auction it's just
outcomes where the highest bidder wins
so again i've changed the terminology
from s to b because i want you to think
about auctions so b represents bids
so the baseline bids again there should
be some optimal outcome
another thing which is now different is
that whereas in a routing game there's
usually only one optimal outcome and
it's something like a first price
auction actually there's zillions of
them right or like zillions of optimal
bid profiles
the optimal outcome is just the one with
the highest bidder wins there's
an infinite number of bid profiles where
the highest valuation bidder
is the same one with the highest bid
excuse me opt welfare is highest
valuation bidder wins okay so as long as
the
max value bidder is the same as the max
bidding bidder
we have optimality so there's a large
number of options of b star and we'll
exploit that
again we're going to just now want to
prove it a smoothness inequality for all
possible other outcomes again i've
changed the notation to b
now this thing is going to change in a
couple ways some of it's cosmetic and i
don't want you to worry about it
routing games you you think about
minimizing cost auctions you think about
maximizing payoffs and welfare
so this is going to flip and this will
become a minus just because we switched
from a min objective to a max objective
okay so that's obviously conceptually
not important the other thing is
that i'm going to just set mu equal to
one for simplicity okay because that'll
cover the applications i want to talk
about today
so i'm following a version of the
smoothness
say it again uh so when you switch to
a max for min yeah so there's a couple
things going on with some
i'm shoving over to the right exactly
exactly
so i'm following a proposal circonus and
tardis here to have a version
an incomplete information version of
smoothness which is really kind of
optimized to get the right bounds
uh for auctions okay rather than more
general games of things bleed
information
you switch to the costuming you utility
domain or used to think you can add
constants to people's utilities and not
change things
but these ratios like to change when you
add the constants so what's the right
notion of i mean
it still goes to me that the ratio is
before or you subtract something off the
correct frame i'm basically going to
assume that value the valuations are in
units of dollars and i'm just going to
be interested in approximating the
dollar amount
so it's not clear how to really
interpret these relative approximation
ratios
without you know fixing some units for
which relative approximation makes sense
your ratio you will get if we have one
guy with value one and one rfi you can
it'll be different than find guard two
and twelve we could just add
a dollar with value that's right
numerically with a different answer
but okay yeah so i mean this is like so
in ricky's talk he talked about some of
the differences between additive versus
multiplicative approximation
both have you know both are one is more
meaningful than the other depending on
the setting
here i mean you know i mean just because
of
the setup here you're not going to have
additive approximations because
everything's scale and variant
right so somehow you think about welfare
you think about equilibria you know if i
just change the units of dollars if i go
from dollars to pennies
nothing changes and the price of energy
doesn't change which is exactly what you
want
but as soon as you're sort of robust as
soon as you're scaling variance in this
sense
um it looks to me that kind of the same
situation
that had to change the value of the
baseline case
but i mean it's debatable right i mean
like if you wanted to measure like
income inequality you know when you
added a large number to everybody
you know their additive difference you
know would still remain the same
but maybe there'd be a feeling that it
was more equitable than when we started
because the ratios would be different
possibly
but but drew's suggesting adding one to
their utility everywhere so
they're forgetting the object is one
more utility for not getting up just
also one more sure
and so that's different from the thing
that nikhil is asking about
i guess you'd be like there's also a
normalization assumption that at zero
yeah so if you okay that's that's a good
point
uh so thanks for clarification jason so
yeah on the other hand if you shift
upward all these results just get better
if you shift downward just pushing all
the way down to zero
exactly exactly but i should have said
that so that's that's the right answer
for your question
good okay so let me just i don't run out
of time so let me
just get through this last piece so
this is now the analog of the smoothness
condition
okay so the c's change to use that's
just because
uh we're talking about auctions
and there's still the lambda lambda
still gets multiplied times the optimal
thing
which in this case is the opt welfare
and uh
you know talking about revenue this sort
of now only makes sense because we're
talking about auctions and there's a
notion of payments and so on
okay and again you can have a version
with the mu if you want but i'm going to
suppress it
okay so this is the new smoothness
condition
and then now before we were extending
the no regret sequences to land over one
minus mu now we're going to extend the
bayes nash equilibria
and mu is one and it turns out when the
dust settles the right answer is going
to be lambda
okay so you want you want to think about
lambda here as something
at most one the closer to one the better
okay
so this is the plan okay this is how it
changes when we go to the incomplete
information setting
all right so let me think about a good
stopping point so let me let me do the
following
so let me explain uh so i'm going to
skip the proofs
but i want to give you an example right
so why was this interesting in the full
information case
okay it was interesting because and what
do i owe you okay so i owe you an
interesting example where you can
establish this
and so i'll state that i'll state the
result for a first price auction
that this actually is met with lambda
equal to a half
okay giving us a price of energy bound
of one half the second thing i owe you
and the proof will have to wait till
tomorrow
is i have to actually prove the
extension theorem to you right so for
the full information case we actually
had this slide where we went through
why it holds for no regret sequences i
need to do the same thing for bayes nash
equilibria and i'll do that tomorrow
okay but let me just
sort of finish the applications of this
okay so again i'm going to go through
the proof tomorrow i just want to do the
statement
consider a first price auction okay
fix the valuations what we need to show
is that for a suitable choice of
baseline strategies
which should lead to an optimal outcome
so b star for suitable choice of
baselines
for every bid vector b the smoothness
condition holds with some lambda
and this is the whole proof again i'll
go through it tomorrow but it's short
you can see
you can prove by this argument that
first price auctions satisfy the
smoothness condition with lambda equal
to half
okay in fact if you use a smarter choice
of b
star you can even improve the one half
to 63 this is the same 63
i mentioned in the representative result
okay so again take away here remember
you have a definition why is it
interesting you need examples you need
implications
here's an example of the definition
first price auctions again there are
many others
there's time i'll tell you about some of
the others okay so you can establish
this inequality in settings of interest
the second thing i do is implications so
what okay and the implication
is that
by again a proof that fits on a slide in
fact
whatever the prior distribution okay
doesn't matter if it's independent or
correlated valuations
whatever the prior distribution under
that hypothesis which we just
established for first price auctions
with lambda equal to half under this
hypothesis
the price of anarchy of bayes national
equilibria is the same lambda
okay so in other words this is an
extension theorem
which says if you prove a smoothness
inequality of this form
it easily implies a bound of lambda on
pure equilibrium of every full
information game
but in fact by this argument it more
generally applies implies a bound of
lambda on the bayes nash equilibria
for every possible prior distribution
okay
so chaining those two facts together
we've learned the following
for every single possibly correlated
valuation distribution
for every single bayes nash equilibrium
of a first price auction
the equal the expected welfare at that
equilibrium is at least half or even at
least 63
with the optimization of the maximum
possible as if
you were always selling to the highest
value bidder
okay and again we knew from the outset
even with two bidders
and uniform zero one and zero two that
we couldn't get a hundred percent okay
we knew fundamentally
analysis of the first price auction with
non-identical bidders is a price of
anarchy question
okay and this gives us bounds on one
side sixty-three percent
turns out if you wanna handle valuation
distributions which can be correlated
63 is tight okay so there's an example
you can exhibit a distribution and a
base nash equilibrium which is off by
that amount
as i mentioned evaluations are
independent we don't know
okay maybe someone in the room has a
better example and they'll tell me that
would be great but the
best upper bound i could find for the
independent case was 87 percent by
heartland hoyt and taggart and so it's
an open question to nail the case of
first price auctions
um with independent valuations
now just to tie this back to the
representative result at the very
beginning of this talk
this looks very similar okay to what i
told you on slide two
the difference is this is a single item
auction and that was about selling
multiple goods
okay but the guarantee is the same 63
it's an arbitrary valuation distribution
so the remains to understand how does
the single item case extend
to the case of multiple items so that's
what i'll spend the first half of
tomorrow on
and then time permitting i'll conclude
with a technique for proving lower
bounds on the price of energy rooted
in computational communication
complexity so thanks
um are there any examples where there's
even like a tiny gap
between what can be proved with
smoothness and what's known
for like correlated equilibrium yes
so in fact that was a slide that i
skipped
so back in the full information case
so in the full information case you can
do a version
you can weaken the smoothness condition
and so it makes it easier to satisfy
so you can prove better bounds but the
concern is that the extension theorem is
less strong okay so you're trading off
the quality of approximation with the
reach of the extension theorem
and so what's the relaxation well so in
the basic version of smoothness
remember the order of quantifiers you
first fix your baseline strategies star
once and for all
and then an adversary if you like picks
an arbitrary s needed to verify
inequality
so in this variation you actually allow
limited dependence between the baseline
strategy
and the adversary's choice s in the form
that the
i baseline strategy s star i is allowed
to vary
with s i it cannot depend on s minus i
okay so you have a version of smoothness
again this is only easier to satisfy
and you know for something like if you
look at those routing games where
players choose not just one path that
can split flow over many paths
it actually turns out you can prove
better bounds using this variation of
smoothness than the original one and in
fact you can even prove more
fundamentally
the worst case price of energy of
correlated equilibria is strictly
smaller
than the worst case price of energy of
course correlated equilibria
yeah can ask the same question for
correlated equilibria
and force correlated equilibrium
smoothness is there any examples that
have a gap
oh okay um so in fact
uh that's a good question
the gap if there's a gap it can only be
very small in the following sense
so i have a paper with uri nadav which
answers the question to what what is the
largest equilibrium concept
for which spoon this bounds apply and
it's a very mild generalization
of course correlated equilibria if you
look at the proof that i showed you
which i think is on the previous slide
almost
uh if you look at this proof one
weakening you can do is that you don't
actually really need
every single player's regret to be
non-positive you just
need an average over all players okay so
if you want that's kind of a
new equilibrium concept where you only
have the equipment conditions satisfied
on average over players
clearly this holds and you can use a
duality argument to argue that game by
game it's not just in the worst case but
game by game
the best smoothness bound provable
actually matches the worst of these
player averaged uh course quote
equilibria so
to answer your question it reduces to
this case you know can you have a game
where
you know the best thing which satisfies
this player by player is you know
strictly better than
one that satisfies it on average i
suspect you could come up with a
contrived one that does it but i've
never done it
so you mentioned in the beginning that
uh even just algorithmically you've got
the same bound in the first
first example right so what about so
that's a computational complexity
argument
what about communication complexity so
these learning algorithms also give you
a way of
communicating information maybe about
complicated evaluation
uh functions and so maybe they even
suggest kind of iterative
auction mechanisms is that yes
i've wondered about that uh so the
question is is sort of
right okay so vince vince proposes an
interesting connection which is
you know so one approach to comptroller
auctions like vcg and making them more
practical is rather than doing direct
revelation and asking people for all
their values of all bundles up front
you sort of interact with them over time
and then there's some understanding of
you know
when does this work have good incentives
when does this not work and so on
and he's pointing out sort of a parallel
with you know if you run learning
algorithms in one of these games with
one of these simple mechanisms
it feels like it's doing it feels like
it's sort of a protocol of the
same form which is iteratively
interacting with the players to learn
something about the evaluations
now in commentarial auctions usually you
do something like a value query
or a demand query so if you sort of like
more directly accessing the information
here you'd have to more kind of do like
a revealed preference to kind of guess
what their values were given what
actions they played
at least if you took this on face value
interesting i've never i've never
seen anything about it but you're
definitely right that sort of the the
learning
the positive results for the learning
algorithms do translate to
communication non-trivial often
communication upper bounds
on approximating say epsilon correlated
equilibria so that's always been an
interesting implication of learning
algorithms
so tim yeah uh the the proof that you
gave for the
auction uh would seem very intuitive in
comparison to your
the proof for routing okay so that's
auction proof you're saying well
this guy bids half his value either the
revenue's high
or he wins bidding half his value in
which case his utility is at the value
and that statement is something that
is fairly intuitive yes versus if you
remember it the first slide will be
algebraics
uh i had almost no intuition for it yeah
so what's what's the deal
basically like why why don't we have a
simple proof for the first one is the
second one i'm saying
you know somehow the smoothness bound
that's on the
right board has some intuition under it
that uh is more clear
transparent than the smoothest bound on
the left or
so actually i i would actually argue
in addition to that in addition to that
i would actually argue that the
conditions on the board
are of co in my opinion close to equal
complexity
but here's what you pointed out which is
absolutely correct which is that
which is sort of like which is more the
proof of how do you establish this with
interesting parameters and you're
pointing out that in the auction world
we were able to argue bitter by bitter
we said for every bitter i here's an
interesting guarantee about i
and then oh we have many bitters we'll
just add them up
so in say routing games it's not so
simple
okay i don't really know an interesting
way i don't know an interesting
player by player guarantee because you
know it's this big
network and you have different sources
and destinations you know and you might
be screwed just because you're in a bad
place in the network and other people
are playing weird strategies
so something that's fundamental i think
about about these routing games is
and it's sort of magic that actually you
can handle both these applications in
the same way because it feels like
something very different is going on
really this is saying in aggregate over
the players some players are bad
but they can be in effect charged to you
know the players that are doing well
in some sense um and so that's my
interpretation of why this is more
complicated
jenny inside of that elias sir
yeah so that's so here you have to
handle all the players
in one shot auctions you can do a player
by player guess in some sense
over on the on the right board this one
player thing
does compare to this aggregate thing
which is revenue
in the one player statement how about
the proposal that because we have a
composition serum
so you can only argue about uh
options on a single item if you could
only argue congestion games on a single
congestable element
that certainly would sound better but i
thought he did
he argued for edge yeah that's
that's right so you have an edge by edge
that's maybe the right way to think
about it
so to follow up on whatever's saying
it's sort of the right way to decompose
the computation for auctions is player
by player
the right way to decompose it for
routing games is edge by edge
and maybe you could argue and so the
work that you do on an edge is basically
these two lines
and like okay i mean the other thing to
realize is like if the optimal answers
are five-thirds and one-third
it's probably at least a slightly
non-trivial computation
right i mean so that's part of what's
going on but um
i would say i mean these are the two
lines that are playing the role
of the bitter by bitter analysis
but you know i agree with you i i do
think uh this is a little more
you know if you just wanted to look at
it and be like oh yeah of course i'm not
so sure how you do that
whereas the auctions you can kind of
talk through why every step is maybe
something you would have expected in
hindsight i don't know how to do that
here
all right see you tomorrow